by and large it was a very controlled
flow of people coming into the country
and and people don't think about like so
Yuma is a good example of how weird it
is because it's not like that giant Trek
people I think a lot of people imagine
going through the desert there's a
highway you can see through the wall
that you're getting dropped off at a lot
of people spend a lot of money to get
flown into the Mexicali Airport then
they get driven to that Highway there's
people set up in tents along the highway
send you camouflage gear water
cigarettes you walk like 30 minutes to
the wall and then border patrols there
like TSA it's like soft TSA they got
water for you they got a tent they tag
your bags literally they got they had an
easier time talking to border patrol
than I did yeah when I was down there we
couldn't get Hotel I actually went down
there with representative Paul goar and
his team and we couldn't get hotels in
Yuma because the federal government had
booked the vast majority of them for
illegal immigrants yeah it seemed like
such a controlled portal because the the
immigrants don't stay there either they
like they're there they get they get uh
plane tickets bus tickets yes send right
out